man what a perfect song on the way to
work this morning i was listening to my
friend
andrew osenga cd it's his latest record
called the painted desert and good folks
you know we
we hear about the beatles and this
you know the the other greatest band of
all time poison
we've all got our favorite rappers and
whatnots occasionally you got a buddy
who's like hey i got a new cd out and
you listen to it
i remember hearing the cd a few years
ago it was at four in the morning and i
was on the way to a trip into the woods
and i almost called him but i was crying
and then i thought ah we're friends i
don't know you that well to call you at
4am and tell you that your record's
making me cry
but on that record the painted desert
record is the single greatest song
ever written in the history of earth
when the earth started spinning people
started singing
and all the songs up until now
fall behind this song it's called the
year of the locust it's track number two
on the painted desert record by andrew
osenga
here's the lyrics we try our hardest not
to think about it
who are we fooling we never stop the
longing the hurting the doubting
worn out from waiting for a parachute
drop hey you
and the reflection of the rear view of a
hit and run at the drive-thru
slow down what you're chasing isn't
something
it's just a screenshot of a rumor in
town
and then the spirit moves upon the water
but listen
take comfort and rest in the heart of an
uncivil war and you're taking a beating
there's blood red on your chest he will
restore the years the locusts have eaten
we're all aching for eden and he will
restore the years the locusts
have eaten whoo andy
this is the dr john dolone show